Traductor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Gisela Giardino
Siempre me interesó la ciencia.
Y cuando tuve que elegir una profesión,
elegí ciencias meteorológicas,
hoy ciencias de la atmósfera.
Una profesión no tan popular.
Somos bastante pocos.
Pero yo no quería ser
"la chica del clima".
Quería dedicarme a la investigación.
Y a investigar
aquellos fenómenos extremos.
Aquellos fenómenos que ocurrían
muy de vez en cuando
pero que tenían un gran impacto:
olas de calor, inundaciones, sequías.
Claro, ahora con el tema
del cambio climático
esos fenómenos que eran
bastante raros y muy poco frecuentes
se han vuelto nuestra normalidad.
Yo integro, junto con otros científicos,
una organización de Naciones Unidas
que se dedica a elaborar informes
sobre el estado del conocimiento
del cambio climático.
Se llama IPCC.
Estos informes se publican periódicamente,
son la base de negociación
de los gobiernos,
porque los gobiernos los avalan.
Estos informes contienen
qué sabemos del cambio climático pasado,
qué sabemos del cambio climático
que vendrá,
cuáles son sus impactos,
pero fundamentalmente,
tiene las soluciones.
Sabemos que a pesar de que
hace más de 30 años
que se publican estos informes,
a veces el cambio climático
no le mueve un pelo a nadie.
Entonces, los científicos
nos hacemos ciertas críticas.
¿Estaremos comunicando mal el problema?
Cuando hablamos
de cambio climático es correcto,
porque se produce un cambio en el clima.
Pero a veces el mensaje más claro
es cuando hablamos
de calentamiento global.
Y cuando hablamos
de calentamiento global, por ejemplo,
¿saben cuánto aumentó
la temperatura media global
desde la era preindustrial
hasta el presente?
Un grado. Casi un grado.
Parece insignificante,
pero cuántos cambios produjo.
Pero también sabemos que nos importa
saber qué va a pasar
cuando aumente un grado y medio,
cuando aumente dos grados.
Ese medio grado de diferencia
parece insignificante, pero ¿saben qué?
Los impactos son exponenciales.
¿A qué llamamos exponencial?
Algo que tiene una acción de 1 impacta 2;
de 2, 4; de 4, 16; de 16, 256.
Ese es el concepto de exponencial.
Y la diferencia entre que la temperatura
aumente un grado y medio y dos grados
es bastante relevante.
Por ejemplo, si la temperatura
aumentara un grado y medio
con respecto a la era preindustrial,
la cantidad de olas de calor extremas,
esas que ocurren una vez cada cinco años,
si esta fuera la población mundial,
afectaría a las primeras cuatro hileras.
En cambio, si la temperatura
aumentara dos grados
se verían afectadas las primeras
diez hileras de este auditorio.
Las olas de calor tienen
un gran impacto en la salud,
un gran impacto en la mortalidad.
Pensemos que en 2003 hubo una ola de calor
que solo en Francia produjo 15 000 muertes.
También sabemos que la diferencia
entre un grado y medio y dos grados
impacta en la pérdida
de biodiversidad de muchas especies.
Se puede duplicar o triplicar
la pérdida de biodiversidad.
También sabemos que los corales
se van a ver afectados casi el 99 %.
La Gran Barrera de Coral de Australia.
O pensemos en los corales del Caribe.
También sabemos que ese medio grado más
de aumento de temperatura
va a producir que
el rendimiento de los cultivos,
por ejemplo, el maíz en zonas tropicales,
se reduzca a la mitad.
O la pesca se reduzca a la mitad.
Con estos informes algunos países
proponen soluciones.
Otros países lo niegan,
por sus propios intereses.
Y otros países directamente los ignoran.
Nunca pensé que mi ciencia
tenía tanto que ver
con las ciencias diplomáticas.
Hay una encuesta reciente
entre ciudadanos de EE.UU.
que presenta lo siguiente.
Por suerte, la mayoría de los ciudadanos
manifestaron que el cambio climático
los había impactado,
regionalmente y hasta personalmente.
Pero otro resultado
muy interesante es que,
dependiendo de su partido político,
si son republicanos, aunque tengan
mucho conocimiento científico
"no creen" que es el hombre
el causante de cambio climático.
En cambio, si son demócratas,
cuanto más conocimiento científico tienen
más certero es que el cambio climático
es producido por la acción del hombre.
Otra crítica que nos hacemos
cuando comunicamos el problema
es que comunicamos los resultados
con un cierto nivel de incertidumbre.
Y a veces de esa incertidumbre
se toman los negacionistas.
Pero tenemos muchas certezas.
Sabemos que la temperatura va a seguir
aumentando si seguimos como estamos,
sabemos cuánto y cómo,
sabemos que el nivel del mar
va a seguir creciendo.
Y podemos cuantificar
cuántos millones de personas
que viven en las costas bajas de la India,
por ejemplo, sudeste asiático,
en las islas,
van a tener que desplazarse
debido al aumento del nivel del mar.
Sabemos que el Río de la Plata
va a seguir aumentando.
Y va a producir inundaciones
en barrios que están
sobre su costa, por ejemplo.
Sabemos que los hielos
se van a seguir derritiendo.
Tenemos muchas certezas.
Pero también tenemos certezas
sobre las soluciones.
Las soluciones están y no se necesita
mucho mayor desarrollo tecnológico.
Las soluciones están disponibles.
Concentrémonos en tres.
El uso del plástico.
Reducir el uso del plástico,
sobre todo el de un solo uso,
tiene un doble impacto positivo.
No solo no produce contaminación
en el medioambiente,
sino que también
evitamos utilizar más petróleo
para fabricarlo nuevamente.
La forma en la que nos movilizamos.
Debiéramos poder movilizarnos
en medios de transporte público
que utilicen energías renovables.
Debemos tener presente esto
para reclamarle a nuestras autoridades.
El tercero es la producción
de todos los elementos
que utilizamos y compramos.
Esa producción debería tender
a ser regulada
para utilizar energías renovables.
Parece difícil. Parece imposible.
Pero hay muchos ejemplos positivos.
¿Se acuerdan del agujero de ozono?
El ozono es un gas que cubre
la Tierra y es vital para la vida,
es muy importante para nuestra vida;
en los años '80 se descubrió
que había empezado una disminución
en la capa de ozono,
lo que se llamó agujero de ozono.
Y también se supo qué era lo que
ocasionaba ese agujero de ozono.
Eran ciertos gases que el hombre
fabricaba para otros usos,
los clorofluorocarbonos.
En 1987, se firmó un protocolo
en la ciudad de Montreal
-- el famoso Protocolo de Montreal --
que determinó que
todos los países del mundo
dejaran de fabricar clorofluorocarbonos
y lo reemplazaran por otros gases.
Lentamente se dejó de fabricar
y hoy el ozono se está recuperando.
En la salud hay muchos ejemplos.
Cuando aparece el SIDA,
era una enfermedad mortal.
Hoy, por suerte, es crónica.
La reciente imagen del agujero negro,
¿cómo se logró?
Se logró porque todos los países
fueron hacia un mismo objetivo,
compartieron su tecnología
y sus conocimientos,
para obtener una imagen.
Pero también tenemos ejemplos positivos
hoy en día en nuestra juventud.
Pensemos todos en Greta,
esta estudiante sueca
que hace pocos meses empezó esa huelga
y se sentó frente a su parlamento
con una pancarta
que decía "accionen contra
el cambio climático".
Su perseverancia en la lucha,
su mensaje tan claro,
hizo que hoy haya más de un millón
y medio de estudiantes en todo el globo
replicando estas acciones.
Porque, claro, la información está.
La información está, pero quizás Uds.
no saben cómo los va a afectar directamente
en sus actividades o en sus lugares
donde están viviendo.
Entonces, la información está pero
no está democráticamente distribuida.
Quizá no está transparentada.
Saben que a esta época algunos
geólogos la llamaron antropoceno,
una nueva era geológica,
desde la Revolución Industrial
hasta el presente.
Una nueva era geológica, ¿por qué?
Porque el hombre interactuó tanto
con la naturaleza
que produjo el cambio en el clima.
Entonces, si el hombre
es el que produjo el cambio en el clima,
el hombre es capaz de repararlo.
Cada acción, cuenta.
Cada día, cuenta.
Cada grado de temperatura, cuenta.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)